[Music]
everybody welcome to planet coaster
College today I'll be talking about the
Infinity coaster known in game as the
infinite coaster so yeah I'm pretty sure
that they are referring to the real-life
infinity coaster with this one it's
coming out in the classic rides
collection DLC today and while I
normally don't really know what to do
with these kinds of early access for
youtubers because I don't usually like
to make these overview videos of new
rides and things like that I think it's
a good idea to just turn these into
opportunities for a coaster college
returns and this time I need to thank
Rudy for giving me his early access
codes because I actually missed it and
he doesn't have time to record anything
so I got his codes for this one so thank
you really
I am glad that I could release this on
the release date of the DLC on your
behalf so to talk about the Infinity
coaster itself I kind of struggled to
think of a planet coaster college topic
for this coaster because it's just so
versatile and I've had versatile
coasters on this before and I always
just kind of go over the different
options that you have and explain that
I'm just going for this one particular
thing but there are also other things
that you can do with it but with this
coaster the options are basically
infinite excuse the pun because that's
really the idea behind the coaster model
if you go to the brochure which I'll
link down in the description where a
girl our the manufacturer talks about
this coaster model really the point is
to allow parks to ask for anything and
they can deliver with this model so it's
really hard to say exactly what you
should do with this there are ten of
them in real life right now counting the
ones that are still in under
construction and almost every one of
them is completely different from the
other ones
there are some general trends but they
can have lift hills different types of
lift hills even they can have launches
they can be indoor dark ride coasters
they can be outdoor they can be shuttle
coasters going through this station they
can be more you
kind of shuttle coasters like we're
seeing in the ones that are under
construction at the moment there's just
way too much to keep in mind here so
overall what I would recommend for this
most of all is to check out the roller
coaster database which I'll also link in
the description as well to see what kind
of layouts they have in real life and
see what these things generally look
like but aside from that this is a great
coaster type to pick and it just come up
with your own outlandish ideas for
layouts and just try them because this
is the kind of coaster type where you
can just try anything really that said
in this video I still want to go over
some of the general trends the things to
keep in mind when you're building a girl
hour coaster specifically because I
haven't made a video on the Eurofighter
and also just some elements and things
like that that you can build just to
throw some ideas I'm also going to
criticise the coaster type a little bit
which is not per se the intention of
this series but I'm still gonna do this
partly also because I'm just really
happy that this is in the game so I'm
not too afraid to be a bit harsh with it
I've always wanted to see an infinity
coaster in the game so when I opened the
early access version of the DLC I
couldn't believe that it was actually
finally here now and it's really great
it looks really nice but there's a few
nitpicks that I have about it and some
of them are very relevant to making
layouts as well and the one that I want
to start this video off with because it
pretty much dictates what your layouts
are going to be like is the friction
I've noticed that this right seems to
have a little bit more friction than it
really should and to sort of test this
I've put this little setup here where
I've got a Eurofighter over here and
I'll put that on test and I've got the
Infinity coaster over here and I'll put
that on tests as well and unpause the
game and what you'll see is that the
Infinity coaster is going to long
slightly ahead of the Eurofighter that's
just how things work but then when it
comes to it they pretty much stay
exactly at the same speed and by the end
of the track which is all the way over
here they've all come to a complete
standstill and they're both in the exact
same position so you would think this is
this is fine and this would be good
friction but in reality the Eurofighter
is set to the regular friction
multiplier of one and I set the Infinity
coaster to a friction multiplier of 0.9
so the first thing that I would
recommend is change the friction
multiplier on this thing set it to 0.9
I've noticed when I was building some
test layouts that it was going slower
than I expected so I set this up and
realize that this thing slows down
faster than the Eurofighter which
honestly in real life it might
definitely slow down a little bit faster
but it loses quite a bit of speed and
from what I've seen it's a little bit
too unrealistically slow so if you want
to try and build some realistic layouts
or if your coaster is even slightly too
slow in general really look at the
friction set it to 0.9 0.8 might even be
good but if you're going for realism
I think 0.9 is the best multiplier to go
with normally I would strictly not use
the friction multiplier because I try to
keep things realistic it's it can
quickly become a sort of cheats where if
your coaster doesn't make the layout you
just change the friction and by doing
that make the coaster more unrealistic
but in this case I think you need to set
the friction lower in order to have it
be more realistic so yeah that's one
thing another thing is the coaster
itself which is noteworthy and I'll look
at the trains real quick here
because there are very different
versions of the Infinity coaster the the
trains are as versatile as the coaster
itself I'd say and most people talk
about first generation and second
generation infinity coasters we're the
first generation is the smiler which has
the
sit down cars with over-the-shoulder
restraints and the second generation is
basically all of the other ones with
more flawless looking trains and lap
bars and the model and game seems to be
kind of a combination of both of these
so we have the trains which obviously
look very much like the smiler trains
but they also have lap bars so kind of a
combination here not too sure what to
think of that to be honest but just so
you know when it comes to realism it's
it's bit of an in-between kind of car
here not that that matters too much but
something that does matter quite a bit
and actually change the coaster for this
is the way that the cars work so you
notice that one of these works as one
car and if I set the coasters to two
cars you sort of get four cars really
and the thing that I've noticed about
this is the reason that it works this
way let me bring the end of the track
back in here is because it seems like
it's just using this zero car and the
second car as a single car and what I
mean by that is easily shown when we get
a little decline so if I built this like
this and have it go over the little drop
you'll notice that the two cars are
parallel over here and the two cars are
parallel over here now in real life the
first two cars of Infiniti coasters and
I believe this is always the first two
cars although it can possibly also be
the last two I haven't seen it on every
single coaster but realistically any two
cars will have to be parallel and then
the rest can move individually and this
is because of engineering reasons it
makes sure that the cars don't fall over
but in the game you basically have to
get two cars parallel both in the front
and in the back so bit of a strange is
set up here to be honest but that's just
how things work you either get two cars
or four cars or rows I should really say
because it's gonna get a bit complicated
that this is really a two car train
while realistically this is honestly
really a four-car train so yeah that's
something to keep in mind aside from
that it's good to have the trains this
length girl hour also says that the
trains of this Kosar type are at most
four cars long even though they are the
only one that is five cars that they've
they have built one that is five cars in
gold rush in slow harden but we'll just
forget about that one maybe they're just
not internally consistent but yeah that
is all I wanted to note about this
coaster itself let's go over some of the
options that we have to build stuff with
this and this really shows you just how
versatile this coaster is I think this
is the largest amount of options that
we've had in any coaster ever so we have
the standard track which is a three tube
thrust track we have the sort of smaller
track that you can use for brake runs
things like that the chain lift which is
a regular chain lift which doesn't come
with a catwalk for some reason but it's
good to have a regular chain lift on
this as well it's something that was
missing on the Eurofighter track and
that kind of made it hard to make
different types of coasters with the
Eurofighter but this one actually has a
regular chain lift as well which is nice
to see and means that you can even put
different kind of trains on this track
and try other coaster types with it
anyway there's a second type of chain
lift which is the rounded chain lift and
this is something which you'll see on
some infinity coasters which are very
similar to the girls'll our euro
fighters if not a little bit bigger it's
just a vertical lift hill with a
slightly beyond vertical drop and even
that a signature catwalk action with the
elevator on the side here for
evacuations which is super cool so this
is what this tower looks like but
there's also a second type of chain lift
and this is a rather unique one so far
there only exists one coaster with this
kind of lift and drop in the world and
once I built this it's gonna be pretty
clear I think through some coaster nerds
this is the lift hill of hang time
Knott's Berry Farm which has this really
long break run that stops two riders
just before they crawl over the drop to
move into a beyond vertical drop kind of
like takabisha but without the super
steep beyond 120 degrees drop so very
cool to see that unique elements in here
and finally we have some of the other
standard pieces that we see with the
other very flexible coasters in planet
coaster drive tires and an allison motor
which is good for launches there's also
a holding section for this which I'll
get back to later but this basically
allows you to hold the car for a while
some friction brakes
some trim brakes and some log sections
so all of the basic stuff plus a bunch
of unique lift tails basically okay so
you can find the Infinity coaster next
to the other typhoon coaster they are
both called typhoon which is kind of
funny although I guess they are very
similar in a way the Infinity coaster is
just sort of a step up from the
Eurofighter so I'm gonna raise my
station up in the air a little bit as
per usual and I'll make it a bit smaller
as well because in this case I want to
make a launched Infinity coaster which
tend to start a little bit up in the air
partly because that's just how a coaster
stations be but also partly because they
tend to have a rolling start to their
launch and this is a very typical girl
hour thing I've noticed usually they go
into the launch with a little bit of
speed and they don't stop just before
the launch like some other coasters do
so I want to get a bit of speed before
we move into the launch section right
away over here so I'm gonna curve around
a bit as well turn on angle snap to get
a perfectly 60-degree curve and let's
start going down that's also turn on the
banking offsets
and that should be a good way to get
straight into the launch so let's change
this to a small track because we don't
really need all of that big track yet
and let's get straight into the launch
so I want to make this about four pieces
of eight meters and I'll turn on the
optional catwalk and have the NSM and
also these launches tend to be quite
forceful in fact I think girl our
launches are kind of underrated I really
liked them so now I have about four
sections of the
that should get us up to decent speed
you were still not looking very smooth
oh well forget about it we'll get back
to that later and then it is time to get
into the rest of the layouts now what
I'm thinking with this is to start off
with a top hats because these things
love to start off with the top hats or
at least have a top hat somewhere in the
layout you don't see as many top hats on
the Infinity coasters that have lift
hills but the launch ones definitely
always do so gonna take this piece maybe
about 11 meters and move to slightly
smaller piece as we go up here or maybe
maybe notes maybe I'm just gonna go very
steep right away just like that
I'll start testing in the meantime to
see if I'm actually kind of make it and
we'll move to the side to create the top
hat here not with the banking with the
actual curve okay yeah I'll make this
one smaller and then we should hit a
decent speed on the top of the lid of
the top hats and I'll take even smaller
pieces here generally I think that it's
it's a good tendency to try and use
smaller pieces the higher up you go or
the lower your speed is that's just how
things tend to work I suppose and I'll
make the top hats the top of the top hat
really tight like that and before I
smooth that out I just want to see if
the speed is any good who would that's a
little bit too fast actually make that a
bit bigger maybe something like that
should be good oh yeah that is beautiful
alright let's head down make this a bit
of a smaller piece here and start the
pullouts
around here and again I want to go for
slide a kind of gradual curve where I
end up close to the ground eventually
and I always just don't pay too much
attention to the shaping of the track at
this point everything is going to change
as soon as you smooth it out so it's
really not too important and next I want
to head into a vertical loop which I
think will be good to add
points these things like to have a lot
of inversions so that is definitely
something to note I think and as for the
loop as well I'm gonna make this tighter
and tighter as we get to the top to
create that signature god what do they
call that again that upside-down
teardrop shape but the weird scientific
name for it I suppose that loop is gonna
be very slow that needs to be a little
bit lower yeah definitely all right now
make you smaller a cloth ID that's the
name so I want to start going to about
an angle like this I think and again
I'll smooth that out later
it's not too important yet but at this
point I want to start moving into the
yeah there we go
moving into going straight again and
I'll move a little bit to the side so
that I don't run into the other track
and start to get a little bit more steep
here as a general idea for the inversion
I think that looks about good now I'll
get to some of the more specific parts
of smoothing later but for now I really
want to work on this top hats because
this is gonna be weird when you're in
the coaster so I want to bank this a
little bit to the side and kind of make
the part of the Bank come as you're
reaching the top of the top hats and
this is always a bit of a weird thing to
get done but with a little bit of
smoothing I think you can get a decent
shape to this and it's definitely very
much a trial and error thing but you
want something that kind of looks like
that and if you can't get it to be very
smooth something that I find works well
for some elements and including elements
like this on the top hat sometimes just
to remove it and go for the auto-connect
feature or maybe from the other side as
well see how that works and want to
watch out with smoothing all on that one
because it's gonna go to the side and
the banking is going to end up all weird
and as you'll see that's not what you
want the top hat to look like it has to
remain straight at this point still I
can do though is adjust the height of
this little bits
make sure that that's a little bit more
smooth something like that there we go
now for the loop I'm just using a lot of
smooth Oh before I get into the
inversion on the top here and to finish
this a moment I I'm really gonna have to
get to this thing and I'll build a
little bit more here just to make sure
that I've got some leeway when it comes
to smoothing because I do want to get
this straight piece into it as well it's
gonna be sort of the exits and really
the most important thing for rolls like
this is to try and see if you can use
the donut to do that quite yet try and
see if you can use the autocomplete
feature to make it a little bit more
smooth because now it's clearly
happening you've got the raw in sort of
two waves you've got one track piece and
another track piece and to try and get
that continuous raw it's just a bunch of
trial and error with smoothing to get it
right and I'll see if I can get it with
the autocomplete here might actually
want to get straight into it oh god that
is definitely not working I'll try and
fix the way out of this yeah I'll go
with that
I was actually kind of wanting to go for
more hang time but I couldn't get it to
look very good that said go slow
sometimes is there's really kind of
quirky elements and really if there's
any kind of coaster where you want to
try new inversions or come up with new
elements I think the Infinity coaster is
one of the best coasters to do that kind
of thing with not that this is a new
element per se it's just any moment that
kind of throws out very quickly anyway
let's get into the next one and next I
want to try an air time here actually
because you do see quite a few of these
sometimes my reference point here is
mostly gold rush which has a really cool
very floater airtime Hill on it but even
Karin on for instance in Hansa Park has
a lot of air time on it so want to stay
kind of close to the ground here make
this quite a bit lower than the Immelman
again
and as we get up here actually I'll make
this bit more drawn out as we get up
here I'm gonna make the pieces that I'm
using smaller as well that looks about
good maybe a little bit too slow so I'll
make that tiny bit smaller but really I
think overall it looks pretty strong
actually I just need to make the top a
bit smaller I think I'm not going for
crazy ejector airtime on this just a
very sustained floaty airtime and here
is also a reminder not to just look at
the coaster itself but to look at the
g-forces here I'm seeing this float at
around zero so that's kind of what I'm
looking for for this one so I'll take it
and next I want to get into a curve kind
of on a higher position here
very similar to what goldrush does so
I'll Bank this track here and do a quick
over banked turn alright I actually
really like the look at that and on
curves like this the smooth or button
really works best and the same honestly
goes for these hills as well I've
noticed that smooth heights and smooth
turn both help because Heights only
really changes the height but as long as
you don't interfere with any banked
pieces so for instance if I start
smoothing out this whole section it's
gonna do all kinds of weird things to
the banking which I don't want any I
don't want any if that's but this over
here doesn't have any banking or curves
so this is gonna be fine to just hit it
a bunch of times with the smooth
albertson and it should be more or less
good also by smoothing just in sections
like this you do preserve some of that
hard line so you can see that the track
is moving a bit to the side as it's
going into the bank section here so
that's pretty much what I'm looking for
I will hit it maybe one smooth all to
make this transition a bit more smooth
and then it's time to move into the next
element which I'm kind of afraid of
because I want to make a small barrel
roll actually it's almost kind of like a
zero-g roll because I want it to go up a
little bit but not too much but we'll
see what comes out of this alright I
really like the look of this
it definitely has a sort of girl our
tango of trek and supports look to it
and it goes to the role really nicely if
we forget about the fact that the role
looks completely unsmooth at the moment
I'll get to that right now but yeah
overall I like the setup of the layout
so far definitely these coasters tend to
be quite compact and have a lot of
unique elements and kind of have these
sections where they all kind of
intermingle and just a bunch of very
twisty Trek going everywhere there they
seem almost a bit more chaotic than a
lot of other coasters I'd say especially
we catch the coasters like the smiler
which are really known for their
signature chaotic look of the layouts
now it's time to get to the last part of
the track but I do want to have a
straight break run here so I'm gonna
build the break run first to make sure
that I don't run into that issue later
so I'm just gonna keep this very simple
very slight incline as always no coaster
tracks are ever completely straight and
some block sections at the end here and
also regular breaks for some reason the
friction brakes on this coaster have
wheels in them I'm not sure if that's a
mistake I don't know if you're watching
front to you but that's was something
that I noticed so for now I'll put some
trim breaks at the end here to make sure
that we have some regular looking breaks
as well anyway that's it for that quick
break section we are cutting it pretty
close here but that said I want to get
into into a single dive so I don't think
this is going to be too much of an issue
I'm just gonna have to make sure that I
make this piece a little bit more steep
than it currently is and then I will get
to a single dive in a single large
winding piece like that I think that
should be good actually I can't do that
I'm gonna have to make this into smaller
pieces so I'll start off with a bigger
piece and get to a beyond 90 degree Bank
there we go looks terrible but I'll fix
that up in post I guess by that I mean
I'm gonna smooth that out later
alright now I like the setup of elements
here but this single dive is being a
little bit annoying to try and get the
heart lining into this thing so I'm
gonna try autocorrect another time and
see if that can smooth this out however
I'm gonna actually just use the
autocomplete function instead of just
clicking the regular button which might
be a little bit better I'll see if I can
get something good out of this but yeah
as you can see it is slightly different
so if it's better I don't know yet but
we'll see how it runs all right I think
this looks pretty promising and I don't
have that much energy left over after
this small airtime Hill there's really
only enough speed for a few more turns
so that's all I'm gonna do to be honest
I'll just do some quick s bends but I'll
still try to get the most out of this so
what I'll try to do is get some twisted
airtime this is something that I think
can on those quite well as well stay
close to the ground kind of use up all
of that last kinetic energy to still get
some fun curves in is that something
that I'm gonna try to do over here as
well so I'm gonna do this in a very
simple way just get up to a hill and
just in one piece go down again and
start banking banking in the other
direction and that's pretty much all
there is to it and do want to keep these
pieces quite large so that it is still a
bit smooth but all things considered
it's a pretty simple elements I just
really like the way that you're hoisted
out of your seat in some of these kinds
of elements so not looking at the
smoothness here but just kind of at the
speed at which it's taking this yeah I
think that's pretty good
let's go for that so that'll be it for
today's infinity coaster and really this
is just one of the many things that you
can do with this it's not just the
launch coaster and really if you wanted
to you could even add a lift hill at the
end of this lane oh it's just at a lift
hill and just keep going and bring all
kinds of other crazy elements in that
said I
I think that this is an overall alright
overview of what these coasters tend to
look like and what kind of elements they
do it's all kind of wacky but especially
with the launched coasters they like
their top hats and general inversions
like barrel rolls in moments dive loops
and lots of curves especially in the
later sections of the track so that's an
overview I'm actually gonna change the
color scheme a little bit of this though
I always thought that's something kind
of turquoise ish with gray supports
would look good and these kinds of
purple trains something like that I
don't know for some reason that just
fits the coaster a bit better for me of
course I want to write this as well so
let's quickly test it and see what the
POV is like I might actually want to
smooth the first curve out a little bit
more that's alright and into the top
hats a little bit of banking in here a
little bit of airtime on the top of that
into this kind of janky inversion here I
got the banking on the loop and once you
get it it's hard to get rid of it and
get it straight again so try to watch
out for that one to be honest
down to zero zero which is uh not too
unsmooth although although I did lose
quite a bit of heart line along the way
there and another airtime Hill and
finally some twisted airtime Hills and
turns not the most smooth layout ever
but I think it's a good overview of the
different kinds of elements and once you
hit the brakes you've definitely used up
all of that energy that you get at the
start of the launch as well another
thing to note about these things is that
very often I've seen them pop up at
smaller parks so I've mentioned trips
trio before a Hansa park things like
these so parks that are decently sized
and certainly large enough to afford big
budgets coasters like this but at the
same time can handle lower capacity
rollercoasters I wouldn't put a
an infinity coaster in a Disney park or
anything like that anytime soon
the capacity of these things isn't that
high unless you add a lot of block
sections or you use very large trains
but really all of the existing ones
except for the smiler which does exactly
that it has some of the bigger trains
and it has a lot of block sections
except for the smiler all of them are
quite low capacity rides at least in the
grand scheme of things and this one
especially doesn't have a mid-course
brake run even so this is gonna make it
even lower capacity ride I'd imagine
this coaster to be very similar to
carajo or junker or the monster for
instance these are more not quite
big-budget park coasters but still a
really good thrilling coaster for pikes
like that nonetheless finally I want to
mention that this is one of the best
coaster types to use dark ride elements
in as in coasters that might be outside
for a large portion of the ride but have
some kind of indoor elements and this is
a bit of a girl hour quirk as well
they've got very well known outside and
indoor dark ride coaster combinations
like saw the ride cannon at Hanzo park
of course which is also an infinity
coaster and there are lots of other
examples look for novgorod's in Hansa
park as well as very similar or mystery
mine generally these coasters are really
good for having an indoor section be it
the launch or the lift hill or even a
pre launch or pre lift hill barrel room
which these things like to put in doors
as well so really this is a great
coaster to combine with some kind of
theme or story or dark right section as
well and personally I really like that
elements of these kinds of rides as well
anyway before I cut to off-topic here
I'd like to thank you guys for watching
this tutorial and of course as always if
you have any tips recommendations for me
or questions about the coaster feel free
to leave them in the comment section and
I'll try my best to read them and see if
I can answer anything
and yeah that'll be it for today have
fun with the DLC if you have it I'm
looking forward to see some infinity
coaster design soon just because this is
such a very creative and flexible
coaster and hopefully I'll see you guys
in the next planet coaster college